مبروك عليهم هذه البدايه وما زال ما زال
المغرب في دور ال16 لكاس العالم لاول مره
منذ عام 1986 فعلتها المغرب فعلها المنتخب
المغربي وتصدر المجموعه يعني مش موضوع بس
انك تتاهل الى الدور الثاني ابدا لازم
تطلع متصدر لهذه المجموعه لحتى تسهل على
حالك بالدور القادم انك تمشي للادوار
المتقدمه انك تروح لربع النهائي لانه
الهدف مش الدوره 16 الهداف الذهاب بعيدا
ايضا الى ربع النهائي وربما الى نصف
النهائي
منتخب عالمي بكل المقاييس عنده كل الادوات
اللي ممكن تخليه فعلا يصنع التاريخ في هذا
المونديال العربي على ارض عربيه ويبدو انه
سيشهد كلام كبير من جانب منتخب عربي وهذا
المنتخب العربي هو المنتخب المغرب اليوم
المنتخب المغرب عامل تبديلات بسيطه على
التشكيله ما غيرت كثير كانت تبديل الوحيد
هو خروج املاح ودخول همم صبي الذي سجل هدف
المباراه الماضيه بعد ذلك طبعا همم بدات
المباراه بدا المنتخب المغربي مسيطرا على
الكره استغل خطا من حارس كندا سجل الهدف
الاول وبعد ذلك مصيري بكره طوليه رائعه
جدا من حكيمي نجح بتسجيل هدف الثاني
للمغرب في المباراه
وكانت مبينه من الامور رايحه باتجاه
المنتخب المغربي والمنتخب جاي لا محاله
وبنتيجه كبيره ايضا ولكن فجاه بخطا من
اكره جاء الهدف بتصير حاله طبيعيه كثير
مدافعين سجلوا اهداف في مرمى فريقه وهذه
الامور طبيعيه بتصير ولكن هذا الهدف يعني
اعاد المنتخب الكندي الى المباراه وخلانا
شويه نخاف على منتخب المغرب في شوط
المباراه الثاني من سيناريو مفاجئ او من
ربما رد فعل كندي في شوط المباراه الثاني
ولكن مدرب المغرب كان صاحب العمليه ترك
الكره للمنتخب الكندي وعاد للدفاع تراجع
حاول لقصه جهده بشكل الصحيح ونجح بذلك
حافظ على مرماه كان في كره خط على منتخب
كندا بصراحه اوقفت القلوب هي اللي اجت
بالعارضه ولكن ما عدا ذلك منتخب كندا غير
كان غير قادر على الوصول الى الى مرمى
المغرب فرق كبير بالجوده ما بين كندا
والمغرب فرق كبير بالادوات بالاسلحه اللي
موجوده هجوميا ودفاعيا وحتى في منتصف
الملعب وعلى مستوى حراسه المرمى ايضا وحتى
على مستوى المدربين وبالتالي المغرب استحق
الفوز اكيد استحق التاهل عن كل جداره
واستحقاق هذا الجمهور الذي خلف الان سعيد
جدا اليوم بكل تاكيد بهذا الاتصال كبير
بهذا التاهل الكبير الذي يعني الكثير
الجمهور المغربي اللي صبر وصبر وصبر سنوات
طويله حتى يحقق هذا الانجاز حتى يصل الى
الدور الثاني بكاس العالم بعد غياب عن
منصات التتويج بعد غياب عن النجاح في كاس
العالم كاس العالم الماضي كانوا على وشك
ان يتاهل الى الدور الثاني ولكن هذا هو
جيل ذهبي للمغرب اذا بهذا الشيء لم يتاهل
المغرب الى الدور الثاني ف باي جيل سيتاهل
هذا المنتخب هو الجيل الذهبي للكره
المغربيه بكل اعمده من حارس المرمى الى
الدفاع الى الوسط الى الهجوم هذا هو الجيل
الذهبي بلا شك عندي عتب بسيط على ابو فال
بوفال لليوم يعني بصراحه مخوفني ومخوفني
ايضا في قاده المباريات بحال مشاركته بصفه
اساسيه مع المنتخب المغربي بوفال اليوم
احتفال زائد بالكره عدم تركيز همم بيخسر
الكره بشكل سريع جدا تمريرات ومعظمها غلط
الدفاعيه ضعيفه جدا لدرجه انه مدرب كندا
حاط الفوز بالشوط الاول على جهات وعلى
الجهه اليمنى بالنسبه لمنتخب كندا
وبالتالي لازم يصحصح اكثر من ذلك وهو طالع
من الملعب بتحس بوجهه عم يعطي تعابير انه
عندي اكثر عاطي بعض خليني بالملعب عندي
اكثر اعطيني بعض ولكن الامور لا تؤخذ
بالنوايا تؤخذ بادائك على ارض الملعب تؤخذ
بما تقدمه على ارض الملعب يا ابو فاضل
بالتالي لازم انه يستفيد ويرجع على مستوى
مع منتخب المغرب مع ذلك بصراحه منتخب
المغرب كلهم ابطال كانوا رائعين جدا على
جميع الخطوط مثل المحاكينا منتخب اوروبي
عالمي بكل المقاييس واللي بيفرق بين منتخب
المغرب بقيه المنتخبات العربيه قبل ما
يتلقى هدف ما عنده مشكله بظلوا قادر يحافظ
على توازنه بظله قادر يحافظ على الاتزان
النفسي والاستقرار النفسي وبيضل له قادر
يحقق الفوز بالمباراه مبروك لجمهور
المغربي هارد لك لجمهور كندا مبروك
للجماهير العربيه تاهل المنتخب المغربي
متصدر لهذه المجموعه وبانتظار اما اسبانيا
او المانيا او اليابان في الدول المقبله